whoa Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott
reunite for Stormy's second Halloween
the 28 year old rapper and the 22 year
old reality star spent the spooky
holiday together by enjoying a night of
trick-or-treating with their daughter
but a source tells ET the pair is not
back together
quote Kylie and Travis are in a really
good place and are slowly hanging out
with one another more and more they
aren't back together but neither are
seeing anyone else it's Kylie's
over-the-top Halloween bash at her home
in Calabasas was all for stormy and
according to our source it was a family
affair
including a pumpkin patch candy stations
dessert table a craft station for the
kids and more this really is all for
stormy because 12 people coming mom Kris
Jenner and boyfriend Cory gamble were in
attendance as well as Chloe and her
daughter true who adorably dressed as
Cruella De Vil and a Dalmatian
after trick-or-treating with little
stormy Kylie hit the town with her
friends has a fairy finishing out the
holiday in yet another sexy look at
rumored new flame Drake's big bash
[Music]